stoicism stoicism teaches that
individuals can achieve Tranquility by
accepting what they cannot change and
focusing on what they can control namely
their thoughts and actions stoics
advocate for living in harmony with
nature practicing self- disipline and
maintaining an inner calm in the face of
external events key principles include
understanding the dichotomy of control
embracing hardships as opportunities for
growth and promoting virtues such as
wisdom courage Justice and Temperance
stoicism encourages a resilient and
virtuous approach to
life ancient Greek
philosophy ancient Greek philosophy has
three key philosophers that stand out
Socrates questioned everything and
inspired critical thinking Plato his
student founded the academy and wrote
about Justice and the ideal State
Aristotle another pupil delved into
ethics logic and metaphysics their ideas
explored truth morality and the nature
of reality Greek philosophy's impact
endures influencing fields from science
to politics and laying the groundwork
for intellectual Pursuits across
centuries Buddhism Buddhism founded by
sadara gotama or Buddha emphasizes
overcoming suffering the four noble
truths reveal suffering origin its end
and the path to Liberation the
eight-fold path Central is mindfulness
encouraging awareness of thoughts and
actions nervana the goal signifies
freedom from suffering and rebirth
Buddhism rejects a permanent self
advocating impermanence and
interconnection meditation and ethical
living guide followers toward
Enlightenment it's a philosophy
promoting compassion understanding and
Breaking Free from the cycle of
suffering Christianity the Bible
comprising the Old and New Testaments is
the Holy scripture Christians follow
Christ's teachings emphasizing love
forgiveness and salvation the core
tenant is Faith in Jesus's death and
Resurrection for Redemption churches
serve as places of worship fostering
community and spiritual growth
Christianity has various denominations
but shared beliefs include the Trinity
father son Holy Spirit and the
importance of living a virtuous life
taoism taoism rooted in ancient Chinese
philosophy centers on the concept of Tao
meaning the way or the path it Advocates
living in harmony with the taao a
natural and Cosmic Force yin and yang
symbolize opposing elements in Balance
taoism encourages Simplicity spontaneity
and the accept of change followers seek
woo way effortless action letting things
unfold naturally ta Ching attributed to
liosi is a key
text taism Embraces humility
interconnection and alignment with the
flow of the universe nihilism nalism
rejects traditional beliefs asserting
life lacks inherent meaning or value it
questions established Norms religious
doctrines and moral principles
advocating skepticism toward Authority
nihilists contend that existence is
devoid of intrinsic purpose challenging
Notions of objective truth or
morality this philosophy often explores
themes of existentialism and absurdity
emphasizing individual freedom in the
face of a seemingly indifferent Universe
nihilism urges individuals to create
their meaning in a world they see as
inherently uncertain
existentialism existentialism centers on
individual existence and freedom it
emerged in the 19th and 20th centuries
focusing on subjective experience key
themes include personal responsibility
choice and the search for meaning in an
indifferent Universe existentialists
like Jean Paul Sarge and Albert kamu
argue that individuals Define their
Essence through actions not predefined
by external factors it explores the
anxiety of freedom and the challenge of
creating purpose in a world without
inherent meaning urging individuals to
shape their Destinies
absurdism absurdism rooted in
existentialism contends that life is
inherently rational and lacks a
predetermined meaning prominent in the
works of Albert Camu it explores the
tension between Humanity's desire for
meaning and the apparent meaninglessness
of the
universe the Absurd arises when
individuals seek purpose in an
indifferent World kamu proposes
embracing this absurdity living
authentically despite the lack of
inherent meaning don't forget to
subscribe to our Channel and continue
watching to discover more on
philosophies Marxism Marxism founded by
Carl Mars and fried Engles is a
sociopolitical theory critiquing
capitalism it suggests that history
evolves through class struggles with
capitalism eventually giving way to
socialism and
communism Central to Marxism is the idea
of a classless stateless society where
wealth and power are
shared it seeks to address social
inequalities and advocate for workers
rights challenging the inherent
contradictions within capitalist systems
Confucianism Confucianism originating in
ancient China is a philosophical and
ethical system attributed to confucious
it emphasizes moral virtues social
harmony and ethical conduct key
principles include filial piety respect
for elders and the importance of
encouraging personal virtue the analex a
collection of confucius's teachings
serves as a foundational text
utilitarianism utilitarianism a
consequentialist ethical theory asserts
that actions are morally right if they
maximize overall happiness or pleasure
founded by Jeremy benam and later
refined by John Stewart Mill it focuses
on the greatest good for the greatest
number utilitarianism evaluates actions
based on their outcomes and the net
happiness they produce it emphasizes the
importance of considering the
consequences of one's actions on the
well-being of individuals in
society
epicureanism epicureanism based on the
teachings of the ancient Greek
philosopher epicurus promotes otes a
philosophy centered on achieving
happiness and Tranquility through the
pursuit of Simple Pleasures and the
avoidance of pain contrary to Hedonism
epicureanism emphasizes moderation and
the importance of intellectual and
spiritual Pleasures over fleeting and
excessive physical Indulgence the goal
is to attain ataraxia a state of inner
tranquility and freedom from anxiety
cynicism cynics like diogenes rejected
societal conventions and materialism
they valued Simplicity and believed
virtue was better than wealth or social
status cynicism often involves criticism
of social norms and challenging
established values it also encourages
prioritizing self-sufficiency and
rejecting unnecessary Desires in modern
terms a cynical perspective can involve
skepticism towards Authority consumerism
and societal expectations promoting a
more simplistic and authentic way of
life pragmatism pragmatism is a
philosophical approach developed by
thinkers like William James and John
Dewey it values the practical
application of Concepts over theoretical
Purity pragmatists emphasize problem
solving experience and experimentation
as crucial for determining the validity
of beliefs truth is seen as something
that works effectively in practice
rather than conforming to abstract
principles pragmatism is rooted in the
idea that the meaning of Concepts is
found in their practical implications
and consequences in the real world
phenomenology phenomenology a
philosophical method developed by Edmund
hustl explores ious experience without
preconceived notions it examines
phenomena as they appear to the
individual aiming to understand the
structures of Consciousness
phenomenologists suspend judgment about
the external reality and focus on
subjective experience seeking to
describe phenomena as they are lived
phenomenology has influenced various
fields from psychology to literature
emphasizing a rigorous examination of
lived experiences without preconceived
biases feminist philosophy feminist
philosophy is a diverse field addressing
issues related to gender and advocating
for gender equality feminist
philosophers explore topics such as the
nature of gender sexism patriarchy and
the intersections with race class and
sexuality they aim to deconstruct
oppressive structures promote
inclusivity and Advance the
understanding of women's experiences
skepticism skepticism as a philosophical
stance involves a questioning or
doubting attitude toward knowledge
beliefs or claims philosophical Skeptics
often challenge the possibility of
certain knowledge or absolute certainty
they emphasize Critical examination and
the need for evidence to justify beliefs
skepticism can manifest in different
forms ranging from methodological
skepticism that doubts the reliability
of certain methods of inquiry to radical
skepticism that questions the very
possibility of knowledge kantianism
kantianism based on the philosophy of
Emanuel Kant centers on the idea that
moral actions should be guided by reason
and a sense of Duty Kant proposed the
categorical imperative a universal moral
law that individ ual must follow
regardless of consequences he emphasized
treating others as ends in themselves
not merely as means to an end Conan
ethics prioritizes autonomy rationality
and the inherent worth of individuals if
you want to learn more about
philosophers make sure to check out this
video on the great Roman
philosophers